can I show you my fancy bag of clothes
yes I think I've got some good stuff for
us all milk is good want to celebrate
the finish right I got some classics
here come in here wow these are we got a
few of these and then I thought you
might like this one this is like maybe
if you could me style okay yeah yeah do
you want to go sorta you know almost
underarm like that or this is just pure
overall I don't know I think I would go
over armed because I'm used to that one
yeah I'm looking forward to you
embarrassing me
alright here goes nothing
oh holy [ __ ] yeah Wow
it is said not by me but by their nordic
neighbors the finished people are
weirdos Oh their language is basically
elvish they're aloof
and do not engage with strangers or
conduct Smalltalk their hobbies include
competitions such as wife-carrying air
guitar playing and obviously cellphone
bro
whoa and yet here I am on a cool
Helsinki morning hanging out with
Finland's future Olympic javelin thrower
lasse had a lot alone
all right you pick all I had to do to
make this happen was slide right into
his DMS and promised to bring some old
Nokia's it turns out that the Finns are
in fact very hospitable and that their
cell phones are sturdy oh so they are
not
was there a metaphor in all this
something bigger being said about
Finland's nosedive into a technology
apocalypse and subsequent rise as a
vibrant inventive force in the
technology industry I'm not sure but I'm
gonna go with yes and try to prove it to
you what comes next
[Music]
we all know the idea of a company town
but here in Finland so big really
unusual happen it became more of a
company nation during the early to mid
2000s Finland's economy booms driven
almost entirely by Nokia in its heyday
Nokia accounted for 40% of all mobile
phones sold and one out of every two
smartphone sold then the 2007 something
terrible happened to Finland Apple
released the iPhone I've come here to
Helsinki to find out what happened in
the aftermath of Nokia's decline and
what startups have risen to take its
place for starters I'll need a primer on
the decline and fall of Nokia and his
luck would have it this long haired
gentleman david cord wrote a book by
that very title
he also happens to be an American but
nobody's perfect you know when I was
researching this episode were just
telling people what we were gonna do
especially some of the younger people
had already they're like you know was
Nokia that big of a deal
because I remember them being seeking
out the kings of the mobile industry
well Nokia was huge in Finland they were
integrated than everything in the
Finnish culture finns were very proud of
what nokia did it was our success it was
a Finland success
Nokia's started way back in 1865 as a
paper products company plush toilet
paper was its first hit it got into
boots tires cables all kinds of stuff
and then began making cell phones first
for this cool guy in the 60s and then
for all of us can you hear me now
the new iPhone is cool at all life was
grand for Nokia and for Finland from
these glorious headquarters by the
Baltic Nokia poured money into the
Finnish social system and then this
raging capitalist named Steve Jobs came
along and ruined everything today Apple
is going to reinvent the phone and here
it is my life always crazy right because
I remember and this like ridiculously
quick period of time it's not like the
company was wiped off the face of the
earth but I mean it'll just lost the
phone industry when Nokia started to
stumble I started to fail many people
took that very personally it was a
Finnish failure there were you know
thousands of people who are unemployed
in the factory workers software
developers in its moment of greatest
desperation Nokia's phone division
suffered that greatest of dishonours
getting sold to Microsoft yeah it was
tough there's a town called Nokia in
Finland which actually the company was
named for and the day the announcement
broke a vandal went and changed the town
sign to Microsoft okay before upset that
you know we used to be on the top of the
world and now
or on nokia of course still exists and
makes things namely telecommunications
and data infrastructure gear but where
the company used to employ thirty five
thousand people in Finland it now only
employs thirty five hundred gonna pour
one out for the notes
[Music]
after Nokia everyone is always talking
about what's the next Nokia what is the
next big company that will be able to go
international and have such a big impact
on Finland and many people at the time
thought maybe with Rubio Rovio created
Angry Birds one of the first gaming mega
hits of the iPhone age but while they
had a few hot years it soon became clear
that Nokia levels success was not in the
cards eventually we came to the side
that's not gonna happen again we need to
be more diverse we need instead of
having one gigantic company we need to
have a 10 good profitable mid-sized
companies the birds may not have
replaced the notes but they did kick off
a gaming boom in Finland one that came
to be dominated by supercell the maker
of all your favorite games and the
master of your time supercell has only
300 or so employees but it raked in
about 1.6 billion dollars last year 100
million people plays games every day
some of them spending thousands of
dollars to upgrade their compounds and
farms and all of this winning happens in
a strictly shoes off workplace a common
trope among finished startups that
supercell claims to have invented ilka
here the CEO is beloved by his
countrymen for creating Finland's
biggest post Nokia success story
I'm here to find out how he did it and
hopefully score some free upgrades in
clash of clans you know for my kids
when you guys started supercell what
were you trying to do maybe in the
gaming industry that was was different
you know it seems to us that most games
companies they're Oregon organized very
like in a very traditional about
basically they had this hierarchy and
the underlying assumption is that the
leadership knows best what to do but in
in games business I feel that it
actually is the game developers who are
obviously are their closest to the games
we know best I bought double games the
company should do so therefore we had
this idea that what if you would like
flip this traditional model like you
know the game developers would own the
vision of what double games they would
do the strategy has made super so one of
the most coveted places for game
developers to land a job like Seth here
the game engineer on clash Royale who
moved all the way from San Francisco
I had always been aware of supercell not
always kind of looked up to them as a an
ideal place to work on mobile games do
you think you're gonna stay here for a
long time
I bought a flat this week if that's real
put that on camera
other supercell imports like Bryce who
hails from France bring new characters
to life with their fancy pens they fight
among each other to get their characters
onto the most prized real estate the
game startup screen the loading screen
is that light that's the prize that's
the best parts of a masterpiece of
course there's just one problem with
putting the creatives in charge
crazy-ass perfectionism the way this
philosophy is translated is that you
guys are very careful about what you
actually release and that you cancel
games all the time how many of you
killed over the last nine years
there's no dozens or it's probably
doesn't I think there's some story the
Girona playing and and
in the time that you're flying across
some David you were pretty happy about
God got whacked yeah it was actually one
of my favorite games he's ever done I
used to play the lot for example with my
kid son and I really really loved that
game and then I just heard what the team
had got together I guess in a typical
Finnish Finnish sauna and then they had
had a like show of hands but you know
who believes that this is the best game
that they can make and you know I don't
think about many like hands went up and
then they decided well that's if that's
ok let me should just kill it
how did you explain that to your kids oh
you know have you run this day I dunno
that's me some doesn't call myself like
the least least powerful CEO my goal is
that teams make you know most difficult
all of all of the decisions which of
course means means that I make very
little or no decisions so let's say that
supercells games are exactly good for
you but I will say that these fine
people seem to be having a good time
making them and bringing ungodly piles
of cash to their homeland in the process
and you're telling me you cannot get my
son Jules now go outside and play
[Music]
to see what's next for the finished tech
scene i scooted right into a former
hospital which has been turned into a
startup incubator called Maria 0/1 this
place has it all
Gurney's more Gurney's tunnels full of
startup refuse wheelchairs hanging from
the ceiling and a cemetery right outside
where venture capital goes to die this
hospital is founded in 1990s
and then we took over 2016 so currently
we serve over 130 startup companies
it's the largest startup campus in the
Nordics the startups here make all types
of things from games to corporate
software but the freshest startup in
Moorea zero one is certainly Nava which
produces a high-tech version of a green
wall until this is like breathing in
1,000 trees at once all around the world
we see these plant walls but this was
the first one I've ever that I've ever
run into that had yeah a lot of built in
technology into it as well yeah so
instead of a plant being just a
decorative part of that we have removed
altogether the soil from the system
almost all of the air purification in
plants happens in the root zone microbes
not in the leaves as people think okay
and if your plant is growing in soil the
air is not touching the microbes we
could rid of the soil in from the system
and then on top of the product there are
fans so it biofilter raise the air 24/7
in your room and this makes the air
purification of plants efficiency over
hundred times more more efficient and
we're talking about you've sold like
hundreds thousands yeah so now it's the
biggest Greenville company in the world
we have about 3,000 units in our our
customers place right now
how kind of bigger vision is how can we
help a billion people to enjoy nature
and breathe forests great air in the
building environment every day
now that we've learned that the shock
paddles have been applied in Finland's
tech scene has come back to life I would
like to show you just how much better
Finn's are as humans than the rest of us
[Music]
it's the annual eating of the herring in
Finland but gossip for safari for one
week in October
people come here to downtown Helsinki to
gorge on the freshest of fish and other
delicious smoky treats they jockey for
position prepare Instagram posts and
enjoy some Tolkien inspired folk
[Music]
yes Jesus as he may have heard life is
good for the Finns the kids are smarter
than yours
their health system is healthier than
yours and my god their parks are parking
our than yours these fins also eat
really well on a square plate is some
old fed lightly smoked pork and boiled
garlic emulsion on top Here I am at your
run-of-the-mill fast casual joint
popping some bubbly and gobbling up a
ham and cheese roll followed by a nasa
inspired marshmallow made out of beets
good that's crazy
[Music]
but the future of food for Finland and
the rest of the world may be here where
protein is grown in a VAT overseen by
the finished version of Walter White
[Music]
this is solar foods with its
headquarters in Espoo on the outskirts
of Helsinki we make food out of thin air
using just electricity water co2 and
some minerals as the main ingredients
have you ever seen Breaking Bad yeah is
there anything else we should know that
happens in here this is pretty legal
okay until the pivot to full-blown meth
labs needed solar foods is focusing on
making protein and other nutrients with
as little water and other resources as
possible no cows no soy fields just
bacteria being fed in a tub by Nature
and harvested by lab coat wearing
laborers
in a sense what we are making is an
ingredient for different food products
so tofu yogurt breakfast bars or any
meal that one could think of solar foods
grab co2 from the fresh finish air and
hydrogen produced via solar panels and
uses this fuel to feed a microorganism
discovered by scientists in Finnish soil
the bacteria is then fed a cocktail of
water and a secret blend of elements
such as iron sulfur and calcium the
slurry of goodness is then dried to
produce a powder that's 65% protein with
a few fatty acids and carbs making up
the rest this is the end product this
yellow is powder protein powder and then
this is just the liquid form of that and
how long is the drying process take it
takes about the day to dry bunkie local
solar foods calls this stuff so lame
powder is it vetted by the FDA yet no is
it safe for consumption I'm told yes and
since I'm the guinea pig for a
technology show my gut is your gut this
is my personal vegan pancake recipe it's
like the regular ingredients for
pancakes pretty much except we're
replacing eggs with with silane powder
that's the magic moment all right here
goes our better
[Music]
yeah you're a pro do you want to try it
first I'll try it this is this is like
the pancake of the future I've never
eaten pancakes grown in a laboratory
before it's a delicious pancake those
dudes may cook a mean protein powder but
the true star of the finished healthier
food movement is this one Maya it Conan
the co-founder and CEO of golden green
golden green makes a vegetable based
meat replacement called pulled oats
everyone I met in Finland eats it it's
in the grocery stores in a variety of
flavors you can even get it at Taco Bell
inside the vegan burrito it's a thing a
brown chunky thing Maya and I met in a
former Nokia cable Factory where else to
try out some pull notes you're not
trying to mimic meat necessarily at all
right you're just trying to make
something that's sort of delicious
that's made from oats that's the exactly
through and and it might be to the final
application it's mimicking you know
because when you make a burger it needs
to be something that feels like a burger
but what actually doesn't mimic is the
incremental instinct ingredient least we
actually want to make sure that you have
few things and they're really healthy
and really clean label and everything is
based on that what are the big
advantages of us it's not meat or yeah I
mean what yeah why yes it's not
originally it's like marvelous it has so
good health benefits for your heart
health and digestion and blood sugar and
it's like medicine you know thanks so
much
it's like a curry
it's delicious I mean I read this idea
anyway
so when we got started we didn't even
plan to sell in Finland
this was like two years ago or is this
2016 but we thought let's just aim to
test it in a couple of grocery stores
then it was so funny because what
happened was that people could entirely
crazy although all the newspapers
started to call us and all the buyers
start to call us so it was like okay
we're gonna sell this in Finland you
know and actually the market grew like
700 percent during that year
[Music]
unlike just about every other company in
Finland golden greens headquarters are
not in a former Nokia building they're
in a former bra factory and it's
elevators real and spectacular this is
where pull doubts come to life so these
are the basic ingredients yes actually
this is oat flour then we have a fava
bean flour then we also have a yellow
pea pea protein but that's about it okay
and then the magic the secret is how you
blend this all together absolutely yes
so we first make like a dry material
based of these ingredients okay then we
start moisturizing and baking it and it
becomes something like this okay so this
this goes through like a machine and the
machine in the process
that's all top secret nobody gets to see
that but I am allowed to see this a
brand new venture for gold and green and
it's sizzling salty and pork ish it's
something that can be made to to replace
like chicken and this is not a debate
Maya refuses to call it bacon but it's
pretty much bacon and it might even be
good I mean that's delicious got all the
like nice salty fatty kind of feel to it
yeah I like this a lot
[Music]
and now thanks to a brave volunteer from
golden-green a better living through
Finland interlude that will come as
quite the shock to my American friends I
present to you a baby a mother and a
baby box this is something that the
government sends to every mother yes or
you can like choose you maybe don't want
this and you can take the money
so it's 170 euros the box is this meant
to be like a crib yes it is like a safe
and comfy place to sleep but also in
this box there is 63 items okay no there
is like the first baby book you get all
these clothes all the clothes in Finland
it is quite common that you leave the
child outside to take a nap okay so
that's why we need a lot of quotes so
the baby's warm they sleep outside
yes that's all seasons or just what it's
the wintertime why do they sleep outside
I think it's it's good for you how much
maternity leave do you get in Finland 9
months so in the box there's also the
hygiene things it is for the baby and
also for adults
you get like a man you guys think of
everything yes I think I know that one
day the American dream will also include
state-provided lube right right
[Music]
by now you're probably thinking these
fins are godless vegan socialists who
have an unnatural amount of concern for
nature and general well-being this is
probably even true they also have a
thing for relaxing in the glorious
outdoors like this open-air Oasis on
Helsinki's waterfront I give to you the
Alice pools
[Music]
steamed to perfection and refreshed and
frozen by the Baltic Sea I returned to
the mean streets of Helsinki to find out
the other ways in which the finns are
better than the rest of us which brought
me here to a start-up and Suvi jaime she
is the co-founder and CEO of sulla panic
and they want to replace plastic with
this what is important in our material
it's micro plastic free eventually
plastic degrades into micro plastic
particles and they stay hundreds of
years or even permanently in the nature
but we have created almost all the
benefits of plastic without the plastic
waste problem the big idea here is to
take waste wood mash it up with some
plant matter and create a substance that
can be molded into all kinds of things
from straws to containers to coat
hangers then when you're done with the
objects you ditch them and they
gracefully turn back into play it matter
we make our materials out of wood and
natural binders and these plant-based
binders they degrade so they can be
eaten by natural occurring
microorganisms ok so no micro plastic
left
Soula pack has pulled in some big-name
investors including Chanel and it
started making its products in factories
all over the world
here are their straws coming to life in
a factory in st. Louis and unlike paper
straws these wooden things actually work
so with the straw how long would this
last compare like a paper straw when I
put it in a drink every second it's
usually melted by the end of the drink
well the criteria is that if you change
the drink you have to be able to use
this one straw so the whole evening
you're able to drink mojitos Frances
which is my favorite drink
what is one straw we need new
initiatives to make these micro plastics
free materials because
there is so much plastic out there you
with one company with one material you
can't solve it all of course if
experimental protein and plastic induced
shame is all too much for you have no
fear the fins still have you covered
here at a traditional finished
restaurant a very nice set of ladies
will set you up with finished gin
scrumptious reindeer moose a ski loaded
with shots and one hell of a bear pie
[Music]
well fed and well lubricated I set out
for helsinki's wooden house district
these beauties were built back in the
early 1900s so that the workers of
Finland could have nice places to live
and nice gardens to tend their symbolic
of Finland's famed social support system
that has made Finns some of the happiest
people on earth
bless you Finland and your wheelbarrow
gardens of course progress often has its
own plans the workers here for example
have been replaced by artsy hipsters
seeking a trendy neighborhood and soon
enough
workers and hipsters all over the world
might be replaced by robots the don't
care about social systems or pretty
Gardens at all hello robot overlords
here at Helsinki is most scenic garbage
dump are some hard-working robotic arms
from a company called Zen robotics the
Zen part obviously being some bizarre
marketing ploy because there's nothing
calming about these things their mission
is to divvy up industrial trash sorting
things like wood and metal into their
own piles how do you get the robot to
see you know that it's not wood that
it's a piece of steel a plastic bag all
this stuff is so amorphous and ever be
use cameras we use metal detectors we
use 3d sends us and we used all the near
infrared sensors the AI is able then to
predict okay what kind of material
we try to understand how is a human
operator sorting waste and he is not
picking it and putting it here it picks
and throws yeah and we simulated the
same movement so our robot opens a grip
and lets the object fly and what do we
know about how accurate the robots are
depending on the different kind of ways
we can go to a purity up to ninety
percent here we go take a closer look
yes okay so the waste comes up it goes
on this conveyor belt and then this is
where it's getting spin and then in this
moment where it's getting scanned it's
telling the robots down the line there's
gonna be an object coming then I want
you to grab yes and then the arms start
to go to work
yes the robot gets to pick which trades
and to throw it in which spin I mean
it's a really good jobs and way of
picking up these objects that are such
different sizes yeah yeah you can
believe that there many men hours
invested to really develop a gripper
what is able to grip total different
kind of sizes shades and I think that is
one of the biggest challenges
Zen robotics recently put its robots to
work right here in the heart of Silicon
Valley at this massive garbage
processing facility in San Jose
artificial intelligence and trash
commingling and harmony just the way
nature intended
back in Finland I took a drive from the
dump to ESPO
it's a city about 25 minutes outside of
Helsinki that is something of a tech
suburb Nokia's once glorious
headquarters are here and so to arts
more sedate current headquarters and the
Angry Birds are here too
but I have not come des Beaux for
disgruntled birds or airborne pigs I
[Music]
have come to see some satellites
[Music]
this is the headquarters of ëyesí it's
one of a handful of startups that have
built small satellites that take
constant pictures of what's happening on
earth how many satellites have you guys
put up today the commercial
constellation that we operate right now
is three solar three satellites and then
your satellites their mini-fridge yeah
and then you also want to try and
surround the earth with with dozens
hundreds of these things right yeah so
we really want to make the system that
allows you to sort of reliably and
accurately and sort of objectively see
everything at the whole times it's
almost like you know having a sort of a
MRI scan for the earth ëyesí satellites
travel from pole to pole every 45
minutes rather than cameras they're
three small SATs use something called
synthetic aperture radar or SAR to pound
the earth with microwave signals from
low-earth orbit they then used signals
that are reflected back from the earth
to build images of the surface
unlike cameras SAR can see through the
cloudiest of days in the darkest of
nights ice I combined this radar
technology with advanced image
processing and computer vision software
to create highly detailed pictures to a
peek at some of these images and walk
through kind of what you guys do so this
was an example of the hurricane durian
in in Bahamas
we were able to image this exactly when
the hurricane was on top of the island
this is the island as it normally is
then in in the afterwards the land
border used to be here and I think
here's a really dramatic thing is that
all of these red dots are me no
buildings you know fully submerged this
is exactly you know what becomes a sort
of insurance information yet proves that
others the flooded and yeah yeah and
then proof is one thing and then of
course in just ability to react it like
now you know what if you could trigger
the payment to these these guys
automatically so that like the people
get to rebuild their lives and so forth
so yeah now here we're looking at large
tanker the grace one it relates to the
sanctions to Iran it became this big
story when it was impounded in Gibraltar
when it was said that it was headed
towards Syria with a tank full of
Iranian oil this is an image from a
while back where we're able to see the
grace one ship here in the Iranian
shores okay in in January so maybe the
US knows where this tanker is the NSA
knows the CIA and they can choose to
make public what they want but basically
with you guys I mean there's a
democratization to all this where anyone
who's willing to pay for your imagery
you know yeah it's not just in the hands
of these few governments now it's like
everybody good yeah can know what's
going on yeah I think I think that's you
know part of the part of the big story
here in the case of this tanker like
what was really interesting is what was
it full or was not full powerful was it
if it's full of oil it's down in the
water and you're getting something on
yeah just the depth from like a shadow
off the water yeah and this is a mine
it's an open pit mine
so you know this is like the more
mundane use case here is just that you
monitor the progress of the mining
activity but of course you know the
safety of is there some display
ventilation you're likely to cause
landslides or is there some underground
mining that is likely to cause collapses
when it started in 2014 ice I was the
very first company to build a commercial
satellite in Finland since then it's
raised more than 65 million dollars from
investors and plans to launch a
constellation of 18 small satellites in
the next couple of years right now we're
sort of fully booked with customers so
there would be some governments there
there would be some insurance some
finance I mean there's like a ton of
positive use cases all the stuff I do
think some people though would be
creeped out a bit right about this
all-seeing eye that is keeping track of
what people are doing I think you know
as far as sort of like the sort of
creepiness honest or personal level I
think a lot of the the sort of mobile
phones you know internet you know Google
type services like they tend to track
you to much higher position and we ever
are so like you know we would never
really be in the business of identifying
humans like you know we don't image
faces or like the resolution is way
lower than that for us it's about
objectivity of being able to provide as
neutral source of information as
possible
hey I robots and super fancy satellites
are all well and good
probably but no visit to Finland would
be complete without exploring its oldest
and most famous tech the sauna or as
they say it hear the sound
[Music]
and since Finland is a tiny place full
of accommodating people I was able to
find not just a sauna but the sauna and
not just any sauna companion but these
on a companion Finland's most famous
actor yes Bert Bach on it along with
having an outstanding 6-pack jasper owns
this beauty he joined me at about 11:00
p.m. to teach me the art of the sauna
and what it means to the Finnish people
when you walk into a sauna you're
stripped down from your clothes your
stripped down from all the titles your
wealth you leave your wallet outside and
it's just a bunch of people at their
most bare state of being and it's really
hard to not be honest when you're so
exposed and so bare so this is a pretty
common thing is to take over here and
hash things out
yeah sauna is the only word from Finnish
language to travel to other languages as
a common word to use and and saunas are
more common in Finn it's more common to
own a sauna that it is to own a car okay
which means every single person has a
song yeah everybody has these sounds but
the ones here are very traditional and
well you know what what is the classic
Finnish sauna the real song it would
always be a would heat would heat it
sauna because the burning of the wood
gives it gives the other song lights hit
this very distinct flavor or this load
right load of the word means like the
spirit of the song I'm going to feel
when you throw water on to the sauna
heaters rocks
that's load and you just get much better
load when you are heat it with wood
perhaps unimpressed by my grasp of the
Finnish language Gasper decided it was a
good idea to complete the sauna
experience by subjecting me to a
ritualized form of icy torture to our
necks and then we take a few deep kind
of just easy breaths
try not to hyperventilate alright let's
see now you start feeling this on
tingling able to breathe now and you
don't feel cold right no good actually
yes once you do it a few times first you
get used to it yeah and then you get
addicted to it so how many times would
you do that during the course of a saw
that session I usually do it four times
back and forth okay so sauna swim sauna
swim and then you end it with via with
the swim I often say that sauna is like
the church for a normal average Finn he
or she goes to the sauna you're in
silence and you sweat out the daily
sorrows both mentally and physically
there's something church like sadly I
think our version is like football game
[Laughter]
[Music]
you